E
END OF DEMOCRACY?
I HEARD MANY RIDICULOUS
THINGS IN MY LIFE.
I CAN'T THINK OF ANYTHING
MORE NONSENSICAL THAN
ARGUING THAT DEMOCRACY WILL
SPELL THE END OF DEMOCRACY.
LET'S TRY TO ANALYZE WHAT WE
JUST HEARD.
WHAT LIBERAL SAID, YOU PUT
McCARTHY BACK IN,
DEMOCRACY IS OVER, KEVIN
McCARTHY IS A HUSBAND,
FATHER, HE WORKED HIS WAY
THROUGH SCHOOL, SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER, STAFFER FOR
MEMBER OF CONGRESS, NOW A
MEMBER OF CONGRESS, HOW DID
HE GET TO BE A MEMBER OF
CONGRESS?
COULD IT BE HE WAS ELECTED?
AS IN BY THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT WOULD BE SORT OF
LIKE DEMOCRACY?
AND TO BECOME SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE YOUR PARTY MUST BE IN
THE MAJORITY THAT WOULD BE
LIKE DEMOCRACY THERE WOULD
BE NO SPEAKER McCARTHY IS
IF NOT FOR DEMOCRACY, THIS
PERSON IS ARGUING THAT
DEMOCRACY IS THE END
OF DEMOCRACY, TED LIEU SAID
THAT DEMOCRACY IS ON THE
BALLOT, THAT IS PROFOUND,
BALLOT AND NOVEMBER, THAT
SOUND LIKE AN ELECTION.
ELECTIONS ARE WHEN THE
PEOPLE GET TO SPEAK, THAT IS
TEXTBOOK DEMOCRACY, IT'S
ALWAYS ON THE BALLOT, THAT
IS THE REASON FOR THE
BALLOT.
TED LIEU AND KEVIN
McCARTHY COME FROM THE
SAME STATE.
HOW CAN ONE ELECTION BE
DEMOCRACY AT WORK AND THE
OTHER NOT BE?
THEN THERE GEORGE
STEPHANOPOLOUS CAMPAIGN
MANAGER FOR BILL CLINTON, HE
WON WHITE HOUSE WITH LESS
THAN 50% OF THE POPULAR
VOTE, DONALD TRUMP WON 30
STATES IN 2016, HILLARY
HILLARY CLINTON WON
20.
HE LOST THE E.
>> THIS THE WAY OUR SYSTEM
WORKS IF HE RUNS IN 2024 AND
WINSIC ELECTRICAL
COLLEGE, HE WILL BE
PRESIDENT AGAIN BECAUSE THAT
IS THE WAY OUR SYSTEM WORKS,
TO PROFIT -- PROPHETS DOOM
ON THE LEFT, HOW CAN IT BE.
END OF A DEMOCRACY WHEN A
REPUBLICAN WINS OR DEMOCRACY
AT WORK WHEN A DEMOCRAT
WINS, EITHER YOU BELIEVE IN
OUR SYSTEM OR NOT, YOU
EITHER TRUST THE PEOPLE OR
NOT, YOU BELIEVE IN SELF OF
GOVERNANCE OR YOU ONLY LIKE
IT IF IT IS WAY YOU WANT IT
TO TURN OUT.
BIGGEST THREAT TO OUR
DEMOCRACY IS WHEN YOU STOP
BELIEVING IN IT.
THE BIGGEST THREAT IS
RELATIVISM, THIS NOTION THAT
WHEN I PREVAIL IT IS
LEGITIMATE, BUT WHEN THE
OTHER SIDE PREVAILS IT IS
FRAUDULENT.
POLITICIANS IN BOTH PARTIES
HAVE EMBRACED THIS DANGEROUS
PRACTICE OF CLAIMING THEY
CANNOT LOSE, YOU HEARD
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS
CLAIM THEY CANNOT LOSE AN
ELECTION, ONLY WAY I COULD
LOSE IS IF IT IS STOLEN, THE
OTHER SIDE CHEATS, THAT IS A
THREAT TO DEMOCRACY, THE
PEOPLE DECIDE WHO WINS AND
WHO LOSES, NOT THE
CANDIDATES.
ABRAHAM LINCOLN LOT OF.
RONALD REAGAN LOT OF.
IF HE COULD LOSE, SO CAN
YOU.
FOR THAT MATTER, WE
CELEBRATED EASTER AND PART
OF THAT STORY IS THE CROWD
CHOOSING BAR -- BARABUS OVER
JESUS.
THE IRONY OF LIBERAL
POLITICIANS.
MUSING ABOUT THE END OF
DEMOCRACY, THESE ARE SOME OF
THE SAME FOLKS WHO WANTS TO
IMPEACH A PRESIDENT ON
STRAIGHT PARTY LINE VOTE WHO
WANTED A PARLIAMENT TEARIAN
TO ALLOW THEM TO ACHIEVE NEW
SENATE RULES THAT MAKE NOT
ACHIEVE AT THE
BALLOT BOX.
THE SAME PEOPLE WHO ARE OKAY
WITH KAMALA HARRIS BEING THE
THIRD SENATOR FROM
CALIFORNIA, BUT GOD FORBID,
JOE MANCHIN ALIKE A SENATOR
FROM WEST VIRGINIA.
ONE LIBERAL MAGAZINE ACCUSED
MANCHIN OF BAILING OUT ON
SAVES DEMOCRACY.
HE REPRESENTS A STATE WHERE
JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS
DID NOT WIN A SINGLE
SOLITARY COUNTY.
THAT KIND OF SOUNDS LIKE
DEMOCRACY TO ME.
NOT THE DEATH OF IT, THERE
ARE THREATS TO OUR FORM OF
GOVERNMENT, INTERNAL ANDIC
PERSONAL.
THE INTERNAL ONES THAT
SHOULD WORRY US THE MOST.
THEY CLAIM ONLY I CAN WIN.
THE ONES WHO CLAIM, IF I
LOSE DEMOCRACY IS OVER.
DEMOCRACY WILL NEVER BE THE
END OF DEMOCRACY.
REFUSING TO ACCEPT THE
RESULTS OF AN ELECTION,
MAYBE.
RELATIVISM, MAYBE.
FEAR, MAYBE.
BELITTLING HALF THE COUNTRY
BECAUSE THEY DISAGREE WITH
YOU, MAYBE.
DISRESPECTING THE RULE OF
LAW, MAYBE, POLITICIANS AND
A MEDIA WE NO LONGER TRUST,
MAYBE.
BUT I CAN ASSURE YOU THAT
DEMOCRACY WILL NEVER BE T